If you travel to Europe now in two thousand and twenty-four,
avoid making these mistakes.
From February you must demonstrate that you are worth
one hundred and thirteen euros a day to stay here.
If the police ask you to demonstrate this and you don't,
they may not let you into the country.
If you travel with Ryan,
you are and your flight is bought by an agency
that is not the company's website,
avoid checking in directly at the airport because
they can charge you up to fifty euros,
so always try to check in through the website itself.
the app.
From the twenty-fifth of April,
if you are going to travel to Venice,
already prepare your pocket and now they will charge a five
-euro entrance fee to get to know the city.
If you don't buy tickets,
you can be fined up to three hundred euros.
To enter the Colosseum you must bring a document,
as now the entries are Nominal,
they will take your first and last name.
If you have no document,
they may not let you enter the Colosseum and end your trip.
Now take the opportunity and send this video of yours to your family
friend OR whoever is coming to Europe now in the year 2024.
Take the opportunity and comment if you already knew about these new changes.